[Musique]
Michel David Chantal Hébert Michel
seoget bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être là
vous êtes un peu plus tôt je devais à
New York la ligne c'est en fumée mais ça
vous aurait fait sourire mais j'aurais
pas demandé de me parler de ça mais ça
vous aurait fait sourire néanmoins sur
Fox News on se déchaîne contre les
Canadiens on dit savent pas faire les
feux de camp ils savent pas éteindre les
feux on est empoisonné ce Trudeau c'est
même pas excusé ils sont vraiment
déchaînés mais les Américains aussi
beaucoup pas juste Fox sont en colère je
referme la parenthèse pour vous parler
quand même des Funny en moins je fais
entendre monsieur Legault aujourd'hui il
a élaboré un peu plus sur les
l'adaptation qui sera nécessaire on
écoute
l'important c'est d'être capable d'abord
de mettre des ressources on est rendu à
un milliard et demi évidemment les
besoins changent rappelez-vous en
campagne électorale on parlait beaucoup
de l'érosion des berges personne d'un
parti d'opposition d'un journaliste nous
parlait des forêts mais là pour on est
tous surpris c'est la même chose que nos
botanique en Alberta donc va falloir
ajouter en adaptation au changement
climatique pour les forêts alors on
s'adapte dit-il on parlait beaucoup de
l'eau là on va parler du feu Michel on
s'adapte dit-il on va s'adapter oui on
va s'adapter la spécialité des policiers
c'est pas de prévenir les affaires c'est
de réagir à dernière minute quand ça se
produit alors et c'est partout comme ça
l'arche blanc ne répond vraiment le
gouvernement de
d'être pris un peu au dépourvu comme
tous ceux qui sont victimes des mêmes
sinistres mais déjà je vois que le débat
est plus ou moins bien engagé quand
j'entends monsieur Legault et les
municipalités commencaient déjà à se
lancer la oui mais qui va payer on sait
tous que ça va coûter cher et
probablement de plus en plus cher pour
s'adapter alors la question va se poser
qui va payer monsieur Legault dit le
contribuable québécois déjà pas plus
d'impôts sur le revenu qu'en Ontario
mais il y a de la marge du côté des
municipalités mais ça vient pas de la
même poche le compte Paypal à la ville
ou qu'on paie à Québec c'est la même
chose et la question qui va se poser
qu'elle est politiciens vont devoir se
poser c'est dans quelle mesure les
contribuables sont prêts à payer pour ça
là évidemment aujourd'hui tout le monde
est sous le coup de l'émotion un peu
comme lors des inondations ou de
n'importe quel sinistre mais quand on va
venir le temps d'imposer des taxes
oranges comme dirait monsieur Legault
c'est là qu'on va voir vraiment qu'on va
pouvoir mesurer la détermination des des
autorités municipales ou québécoises de
pluie on va être ailleurs on va dire bon
ben c'est réglé on a pas plus Chantal
il y a des jeunes générations de
politiciens qui même en parlant de
changement climatique qui est de lutte
au phénomène on passait beaucoup de
temps à convaincre les contribuables que
ça allait pas leur coûter d'argent que
ça et qui aurait pas besoin de faire des
grands changements alors oui on peut
parler d'adaptation ou se dire après 4
jours de pluie on passe à un autre appel
mais malheureusement un adaptation va
falloir que soit à géométrie croissante
parce que dans la mesure où on ne
contrôle pas les changements climatiques
où on fait pas ce qu'il faut pour les
contrôler ça va devenir de plus en plus
difficile de s'adapter à des phénomènes
de plus en plus récurrents et changer de
gouvernement changer de discours dites
n'importe quoi ce qu'on voit maintenant
on va le voir de plus en plus et on va
voir le reste aussi Michel le problème
c'est qu'on ne peut pas s'attaquer à un
problème à la fois on peut pas dire
cette semaine c'est les feux on oublie
les berges cette semaine parce qu'on
peut pas travailler là-dessus tout doit
être fait en même temps c'est dommage ça
va coûter cher c'est compliqué mais
sinon on s'en sortira pas alors il faut
vraiment avoir une une vision la plus
large possible et c'est pas dans la
nature du de des gouvernements Michel
avait tout à fait raison de dire des
gouvernements réagissent ils sont pas
plus très proactifs sur ces choses là
mais il va falloir commencer à apprendre
à être proactif parce que tout est dans
tout là-dedans je comprends qu'on se
régale baudet comme expression mais
c'est vrai alors il faut regarder
toi-même temps les berges les feux de
forêt
les yeux de chaleur en ville tout ça est
lié maintenant et l'argument que je
reçois beaucoup par courriel de gens
d'ailleurs petite parenthèse une autre
on retrouve un peu ces clivages un peu
malsain le dès qu'on dès que le mot
changement climatique dans un titre
qu'on met on reçoit des courriels des
gens qui nous disent vous êtes obsédé
vous vous reliez ça à ça c'est un hasard
il y a des feux toutes les années bon
cela dit beaucoup l'argumentaire qui
revient beaucoup chez beaucoup de
personnes c'est dire oui mais même s'il
y avait un effort par exemple des taxes
oranges un effort plus grand demandé au
Canadien demander au Québec ça ne
changera pas l'ensemble de l'oeuvre
parce que il y en a qui font passer leur
leurs efforts sur la planète et qu'on
ait une petite goutte dans l'océan de la
Terre vous entendez ça j'imagine dans
vos boîtes vocales et dans vos courriels
Michel aussi Chantal et Michel c'est
comme si on disait écoutez quoi qu'on
fasse de les recherches il va toujours
avoir des gens qui vont mourir du cancer
alors on va arrêter de faire de la
recherche là-dedans ça coûte cher c'est
la même chose on sera pas capable
d'empêcher les changements climatiques
et on sera pas capable non plus de
limiter jusqu'à les amener à zéro les
conséquences des changements climatiques
mais on n'a pas le choix que d'essayer
de les minimiser alors se dire ouais il
y en a qui font pas d'efforts puis de
toute façon on sera pas capable de tout
faire
il y a beaucoup d'Américains qui en
souffrent aujourd'hui c'est ça ça
s'appelle comme ça une planète il y a
pas de mur qui va protéger une Canada ou
qui peuvent protéger les États-Unis du
Canada et des effets climatiques et
oui peut-être que tout le monde fait pas
ce qu'il faut mais à un moment donné à
peu près tous les états j'en connais pas
qui seront pas confrontés à ces
réalités-là on n'est pas en train de
parler d'une mode d'une vague de de
c'est du sujet du mois puis dans un mois
on va parler d'un autre sujet plus sexy
c'est c'est avec nous et ça va l'être de
plus en plus et je suis pas convaincu
que la classe politique veut ou que
l'électorat
et rendu au moment où on se rend à la
réalité c'est pas c'est vraiment pas une
tendance là puis on en parlera plus
c'est l'avenir qu'on voit maintenant
c'est l'avenir en accéléré Michel c'est
vrai que ça va être difficile de
convaincre nos politiques convaincre
l'opinion publique aussi qu'il faut
travailler fort quand on voit aux
États-Unis qui a à peu près à moitié de
l'électorat et peut-être encore une fois
un président qui faisait ça n'existe
même pas les changements climatiques
c'est donc une tâche compliquée pour
nous mais en même temps on n'est plus
vulnérable au Canada que bien d'autres
pays sur des changements climatiques
des orages il y en a partout en Amérique
du Nord ce qui vient de se produire pour
les feux de forêt actuellement nous
touchent plus que d'autres régions du
même continent qui ont aussi eu des
orages alors on a une on est dans la
partie nord de l'Amérique du Nord c'est
le cap de dire on va avoir des effets
qui vont être plus grands sur certains
de un aspect et qui et qu'on ne peut pas
ignorer on pourra pas ignorer la
prochaine vague de feux de forêt pour
pas ignorer les prochaines inondations
du printemps alors
on tout de suite commencé tout de suite
puis pas de se dire oh il y en a qui
font pas leur job très bien
autre sujet Michel vous avez écrit
là-dessus hier dans la presse sur un
événement
que l'on présente comme étant
anti-avortement à Québec au Palais des
Congrès annulés par le gouvernement du
Québec qui est propriétaire des lieux
qui a dit on ne veut pas la ministre
prouve vous allez l'entendre on dit on
ne veut pas ce genre d'événements là
donc on annule
l'organisme en question
envoie et déjà va utiliser les tribunaux
en mise en demeure vous n'avez pas le
droit de nous d'annuler notre événement
comme ça ça ne se fait pas faut que vous
ayez des raisons valables on écoute
c'est le 2 juin donc s'il y a quelques
jours parce que ça évoluait un peu le 2
juin regardez tout le monde était
d'accord à l'Assemblée nationale pour
que le gouvernement annule l'événement
on écoute qu'on vit
c'est clair au Québec on veut pour
tomber dans le débat là
quant à l'avortement c'est important
pour nous et je pense que la ministre a
été bien avisé je voudrais quand même
prendre quelques instants pour
féliciter la ministre Caroline prou qui
pour son leadership alors j'ai déjà été
le ministre responsable du Centre des
congrès de Québec et si j'avais eu la
même information j'aurais pris la même
décision
une question aussi de jugement on
n'irait pas permettre à des groupes là
entier avortement de pouvoir faire des
gants spectacles dans des organismes
publics ce type d'événement là ou de
situation là n'est jamais arrivé
maintenant il y a eu une erreur et une
erreur de la part de mon PDG je lui ai
fait peur et ce matin je lui dis que
nous n'allons pas accompagner
l'entreprise pour se retrouver un local
l'entreprise là c'est harvest ministry
international c'est un truc religieux
alors avant de vous faire entendre les
extraits d'aujourd'hui faisant un tour
de table sur cette sur ça on constate
vous le voyez comment qu'il y avait
uneanimité Michel C ça vous a étonné
vous avez écrit là-dessus hier d'autres
que ça étonnés mais ça vous étonné en
tout cas un des premiers je vous laisse
la parole
il fait deux choses qu'il faut dire
là-dessus au début du débat ah ce n'est
pas un débat sur l'avortement et
Monsieur Saint-Pierre la mandat le chef
du PQ c'est lui qui a eu la meilleure
phrase là-dessus on a mélangé notre
opposition à
aux lois contre l'avortement avec la
situation la question c'est une question
de liberté d'expression c'est une
question de est-ce que les groupes qui
sont pas populaires ont le droit de
s'exprimer et l'arbitraire du
gouvernement par rapport à ça le vrai
problème c'est que le gouvernement a
commencé à regarder ça on dit ok on veut
pas de cette chose là parce que c'est
contraire aux choses qu'on que nous on
propose est-ce que la liberté
d'expression s'applique seulement au
sujet ou le gouvernement est d'accord
c'est cette question là qui est en cause
pas l'avortement actuellement et
l'arbitraire du gouvernement parce que
quand on dit on a entendu madame Biron
dire on va faire ça au cas par cas le
synonyme c'est arbitraire oui Chantal on
va les entendre aujourd'hui je vous
rassure mais je sais mais Chantal sur le
sur le portrait de l'histoire au départ
bon mettons que un organisme qui est
contre la charte la loi 21 sur la
laïcité il veut faire une rencontre au
Palais des Congrès est-ce que le
gouvernement se donne le droit de
décider que c'est pas sa position et
donc que les Québécois et leurs valeurs
ne permettent pas ce genre de rencontre
là au Palais des Congrès moi franchement
après avoir couvert le débat sur
l'avortement je trouve qu'on dénature
dans ces décisions là le sens du mot pro
choix trop choix ça voulait pas dire la
position correcte c'est être pour le
droit l'avortement ça voulait dire les
femmes qui veulent se faire avorter
peuvent ça s'appelle choix mais ça a
jamais rendu impossible des opinions qui
sont pas populaires qui sont pas la
mienne certainement pas de s'opposer à
l'avortement la question c'est tant que
ces gens-là ne s'en vont pas harceler
des femmes qui veulent se faire avorter
ou tentent de réinscrire le débat dans
l'arène politique ce qui est pas en
train d'arriver en passant
c'est une décision non seulement
malaisante mais c'est impressionnant
malheureusement Michel j'ai l'impression
que Madame prouve madame Gazal tout le
monde au départ ont eu une réaction
émotive un coup du coeur disant hey on
n'est pas encore pour remettre ça en
question et c'est vrai que le Québec est
depuis Morgan tallaire et
tout ce qui s'en est suivi ont été à
l'avant plan de la lutte pour le droit
l'avortement au pays et encore
maintenant je voyais un sondage pas très
ancien qui démontrait que encore
aujourd'hui c'est au Québec le droit
l'avortement et le plus soutenu je
dirais bon mais ceci étant dit la job du
gouvernement c'est de faire en sorte que
le droit à l'avortement et la
possibilité d'en avoir un quand on veut
soit maintenu pas de museler ceux qui
sont pas d'accord
il faut pas mélanger les choses et à ce
que je sache la liberté d'expression et
ça en fait partie
est garantie par la Charte des droits de
la personne du Canada mais aussi du
Québec et ça aussi le gouvernement le
devoir de la défense et il y a pas de
hiérarchie entre les doigts fondamentaux
alors non je pense que on a simplement
comment dire orienter les bazooka à
mauvaise place et le 2 juin c'est quand
même notable c'est pour ça que j'ai pris
le temps de vous faire des extraits de
tout le monde le 2 juin c'est comme si
les gens qui étaient au choix puis le
sont tous c'est très bien on confondu se
sont dit si on accepte qu'il y a une
réunion de un groupe religieux qui est
contre l'avortement ben c'est comme si
on renie ce qu'on pense et parce que
comment vous expliquer l'unanimité sinon
le retour de table Michel C
je pense qu'ils ont mélangé leur
opposition à l'avortement et d'autres
principes qui sont garantis par l'achat
dont la liberté d'expression et je
comprends que c'est beaucoup de monde à
un moment donné ce n'est le débat ne
porte pas sur l'avortement c'est un
débat sur la liberté d'expression sur le
droit du gouvernement de dire j'ai si
bien contrat et là quelques jours d'avis
je serai le contrat débrouillez-vous bon
vous aidera même pas d'ailleurs puis si
vous perdez de l'argent c'est pas mon
problème on aura ce problème là beaucoup
plus large
de
possibilités pour le gouvernement
d'interbitraire comme ça si on laisse
passer celle-là
Chantal et Michel un mot là-dessus je
vais vous faire entendre aujourd'hui
parce que ça évolué les gens on s'est
dit ouais dans le fond c'est peut-être
un précédent dangereux mais je vais
faire écouter tout de suite Paul
saint-pierre-la-mondon
et Alexandre Leduc qui aujourd'hui dis
ouais
faudrait peut-être réfléchir un peu on
écoute
j'invite tous les élus et tous les
partis apprendre un pas de recul et à
s'assurer de ne pas confondre deux
enjeux complètement différents celui du
droit à l'avortement et celui de la
liberté de réunion et de d'expression
quel sera dorénavant notre politique
pour déterminer qui a le droit de
s'exprimer en société puis qui n'a pas
le droit de s'exprimer
la décision était un peu trop rapide
là avec un peu de pas de recul tout un
chacun je pense qu'on réalise que des
dangers à commencer à aller dans cette
dans ce chemin là il nous mène pas des
belles places je pense ce chemin là
alors on prend un peu de recul on
constate que il faut apporter ça avec
beaucoup de philosophie avec beaucoup de
sérénité
là on n'a pas d'extrait les libéraux
mais j'imagine dans le cocus libéral
aussi à des gens qui vont dire
Chantal pour la liberté d'expression
c'est parce que il y a des endroits au
Canada je dis pas nécessairement au
Québec et pas aujourd'hui mais il y a
pas si longtemps ou des gouvernements ce
serait senti autorisé d'interdire la
tenue d'une rencontre de ce genre-là de
gens qui militent pour les droits LGBTQ
et c'est exactement la même pente c'est
à dire un gouvernement qui prétend avec
raison qu'au Québec on a évacué la
politique de questions qui relèvent la
conscience des gens peut pas devenir en
même temps la conscience qui dicte ce
qui est acceptable ou pas la
collectivité mais en matière de liberté
d'expression je David est-ce que
Caroline Proust parce que là dans
l'extrait disait une erreur de mon PDG
etc est-ce que ils peuvent revenir en
arrière trop tard pour celui-là puis
comment
parce que encore aujourd'hui après que
la mise en demeure est envoyée elle a
dit non non on persiste et on signe il
est pas question de reculer alors je
sais pas comment ils vont s'en sortir
mon impression c'est qu'au départ le
coup de cœur dont je parlais tantôt mais
ils ont eu peur que si ils tolérerait ça
il donnait l'impression qu'ils étaient
disons ouvert à rouvrir le dossier alors
que c'est absolument pas le cas je pense
pas que personne les aurait soupçonné de
ça mais bon là remettre le pantalon dans
le tube ça ça sera pas de la tarte
Michel C conclusion là-dessus est-ce que
vous vous ça sera pas de la tarte mais
en même temps l'organisation en question
je pense qu'ils ont un peu d'argent ils
vont pas laisser ils vont pas laisser ça
mourir ils vont aller en cours mais un
moment donné il va falloir que le
gouvernement actuel se réconcilie avec
la charte des Québécoises des droits et
libertés puis faire des clauses d'un
obstant préventive puis des choses comme
ça ça n'aide pas le débat sur ces choses
là c'est une nuit et c'est c'est comme
ça qu'on en arrive là où on est arrivé
aujourd'hui à un moment donné cette
charte là qui est une loi québécoise
adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale avant
la charte fédérale elle est très bonne
elle garantit puis garantit la liberté
d'expression je m'excuse mais c'est
toujours garantir c'est la parole d'un
groupe minoritaire et pas populaire
alors il va falloir vivre avec ça
très bien monsieur Poirier devra vivre
avec le budget parce qu'il a été il y a
quelques minutes je sais pas si on a des
images mais il a été finalement adopté
monsieur Poirier qu'on va écouter
on va écouter le l'extrait les deux
premiers extraits si vous voulez bien
monsieur poignet on vient tout de suite
c'est une tradition qui existe depuis
des milliers d'années de avant même
l'arrivée des Européens il y avait des
autochtones qui faisaient la chasse et
même après que les Français est arrivé
pour établir la belle province il y
avait beaucoup de chasse est une
tradition qui existe qui existe toujours
il y a beaucoup de Québécois
patriotiques qui continuent de faire la
chasse
hier j'ai prononcé un discours de 4
heures afin d'empêcher le déficit le
budget inflationniste et déficitaire de
Justin Trudeau qui menace la sécurité
économique des Canadiens
bon c'est une bien tradition monsieur
poulain veut pas le premier là il y a
déjà des gens
là c'est intéressant vous a montré un
extrait où il racontait il raconte des
histoires puis beaucoup de députés ont
fait ça Michel c'est Auger vous avez été
sur la colline à Québec sur les deux
collines ça arrive très souvent là le
budget est passé est-ce qu'il voulait
personne montrer que c'est désormais sa
priorité ces questions là ils reviennent
à des questions plus essentielles pour
les Canadiens oui mais en même temps il
le fait la manière poilière c'est à dire
que le principe de trousse comme passer
de Monsieur bolivier il est pas
là-dedans alors lui dire on va siéger
tout l'été si nécessaire pour refaire le
budget arctique par article j'espère que
les sénateurs conservateurs vont faire
ça pour lui aussi j'ai pas sûr que ça va
marcher super fort mais
un moment donné il y a comme chez
Monsieur poyièvre une incapacité de dire
j'ai je suis contre ça je vais le
montrer et quand je perds je perds puis
je gagnerai quand
[Musique]
les Canadiens vont trouver ça très drôle
Chantal vous avez écrit un texte il y a
quelques jours en disant et il faut il
faut mais il faut s'il ne se recentre
pas sur les questions qui préoccupent
vraiment les Canadiens comme l'inflation
tout ça il y a comme un problème il
pourrait rater le train ouais sauf que
là on a assisté vous parler de Philippe
boster c'est bien bien grand mot là pour
ce qui est arrivé il y a plus d'enflure
verbales que que de Philippe Boston dans
ce qu'on a vu cette semaine pour la
bonne et simple raison que Monsieur
poignet hier matin a annoncé à son cocus
et aux médias qu'il allait parler
jusqu'à ce que le gouvernement revienne
dans la raison tout en sachant que selon
une motion adoptait déjà aux communes à
minuit à l'esther et c'était la fin de
son Philippe boster je vous dirais au
Sénat 15 sénateur conservateur sur une
centaine et quelques demandes ça ira pas
loin mais oui c'est un effort pour
passer à un appel plus payant en terme
électoraux que la question du dossier de
l'ingérence chinoise le problème c'est
que oui monsieur poignet dit il faut
passer l'été à écrire un budget ça va
être intéressant au mois de septembre de
voir si lui fait ça ce qui ferait avec
le programme de garderie qu'est-ce qui
coûterait pour arriver à l'équilibre 0
est-ce qu'il maintiendrait les
transferts aux provinces est-ce que les
soins dentaires ils s'en
débarrasseraient à la fin c'est une
chose de dire il faut qu'il réécrive le
budget mais il manque encore beaucoup
beaucoup de chair sur l'OS pour savoir
comment les conservateurs eux reviennent
quand l'équilibre budgétaire Michel oui
moi je pense monsieur Poirier va pas
passer un seul instant là qui allait
forcer le gouvernement à écrire un
budget puis qui avait l'air pouvoir
tenir jusque là c'est je pense oui une
bonne façon de faire la transition entre
l'ingérant chinoise et les clous sur
lequel il doit taper pour pour affaiblir
le gouvernement et surtout vous savez
les Canadiens comme tous les acteurs
font la différence entre une opposition
légitime et du sabotage à un moment
donné
joue le jeu le piquant viendra
l'élection on décidera qui vont être au
gouvernement Mario Dumont à l'époque je
me souviens avec avait perdu beaucoup de
pluie mais il y avait probablement
saboter ses chances de devenir Premier
ministre quand il y avait dit avant même
que le budget soit présenté par le
gouvernement Charrey qui était
minoritaire aussi je vois votre écran je
vois tout faire pour qu'il passe pas
attends ton tour dit généralement les
électeurs merci à vous trois merci
d'avoir été la plus tôt c'est appréciée
à très bientôt bonne fin de semaine au
revoir au revoir